[Music]
hey everyone welcome to their
installments of harry potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing lavender brown if you can't
remember who lavender is
she was a pureblood witch that started
at hogwarts in the same year as harry
ron and hermione she was first mentioned
when she was sorted into gryffindor
house in the philosopher's stone
and was actually the first new
gryffindor of her year as expressed in
the following excerpt
but brown lavender became the first new
gryffindor
and the table on the far left exploded
with cheers but for years
lavender attended hogwarts often sharing
classes with the trio
she even shared a dormitory with
hermione however there was never much
tension placed on her
until the sixth film when her character
really blossomed it was in her sixth
year that lavender developed an
infatuation with ron weasley
and a disliking of hermione granger
fueled by jealousy
friends don't make me laugh she didn't
talk to him for weeks after he started
going out with me
but i suppose she wants to make up with
him now is all interesting would you
call getting poisoned being
interesting despite eventually having
her falling apart with her beloved 1-1
lavender still went on to join
dumbledore's army intent on helping out
with the protection of hogwarts and the
opposition of the death eaters
lavender bravely fought in the battle of
hogwarts but in that catastrophic battle
there was serious bloodshed and lavender
certainly didn't escape
unscathed two bodies fell from the
balcony overhead
as they reach the ground the grey blur
that harry took for an animal
sped four-legged across the hall to sink
its teeth into one of the fallen
no shrieked hermione and with a
deafening blast from her wand
fenrir greyback was thrown backward from
the feebly stirring body
of lavender brown after falling off of a
balcony lavender was brutally attacked
by the infamous and bloodthirsty
werewolf
fenrir greyback greyback was known for
his animalistic brutality
and tendency to target those who were
helpless particularly children
grayback is about as scary as they come
and was essentially a cannibal with
superhuman strength
and an ability to perform magic not
someone you want to meet in a dark alley
now in the films it's quite clear
lavender dies
it's not really up for debate she falls
off of a balcony and then gets savaged
by a werewolf
actress jessie cave even confirmed this
in an interview
what was the last scene you filmed on
the very last film mine was my death
scene which is quite fitting really
but in the books things aren't quite so
straightforward the last time that she's
mentioned was when her body was
feebly stirring and when greyback was
knocked off of her
but it never explicitly mentions that
she actually died
so if we were to go buy book canon then
is she living or not
though it's never explicitly stated that
lavender dies there are certainly a few
clues that suggest it
first of all her injuries are quite
severe she was basically eaten by a
werewolf
after falling off of a balcony doesn't
sound like something you can just
bounce back from next it's likely that
she was never mentioned again because
she wasn't around she had died she also
isn't on platform nine and three
quarters in the final chapter
nor does she appear as a character in
the cursed child okay
sure it's never confirmed in the books
but let's be realistic
did she survive probably not lavender
was also the only character listed on
pottermore as
presumed dead which is unusual what do
you guys think
did lavender brown survive let me know
in the comment section below
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams
and forget to live
you